and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead Jess
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply
learn with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get
ahead simply learn from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time
transformation simply learn industry
expert dat
expert
difficult with a well structured course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that long didn't choose a quick fix he
just added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation you two will find your way to
get ahead when simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
uh hi sandep I'll be sharing my screen
good evening good evening even let me
just quickly share my
screen
e
uh hello everyone we'll be starting the
free industry insights uh session on
what's changing in blog space uh for
2024 and Beyond uh I am your host Rasha
Khan I'm joining all the way from
Bangalore India and uh you can let us
know where are you tuning in from by
sharing your name and uh you know your
location and uh we can have a little bit
of conversation as we start the session
I can see folks have started
uh you know sharing few responses on the
chat here that's great uh would love to
know where are you joining us from on
the chat here let's Network a bit right
like these events are really great for
networking before we even start so uh
yeah I think I can see arind has joined
from bangaluru
uh nakul uh Navin good evening good
evening to
everyone nakul has joined from Punjab
here so uh meanwhile uh folks are still
joining in uh we will be just going
through the ground rules quickly here uh
so you can put on your questions in the
Q&A box if in case you have any
questions uh related to blockchain for
our speaker who's already joined us uh
uh in the Q&A box here you can easily
navigate it uh by basically going uh
just beside the chart box uh if you're
joined from mobile or a laptop so it'll
be easier for us to uh take your
questions there uh also the session is
being recorded in case uh you want to go
through the recording of the session
again in case you missed out anything uh
you can expect a followup email from us
with the recording link webinar
certificate and bonus offer for the
program which we'll be talking about for
attending this webinar so we'll be
revealing that uh towards the end of the
session and also to request a proof of
attendance for this webinar uh you can
enter your full name in the post webinar
survey that you'll be getting once we
end the webinar so I think I can U
basically um clear any query you have
about the attendance part towards the
end of the session so let's start the
session for now so so let me take you to
the agenda of today's session uh so
we'll be starting uh with getting to
know a little bit more about you uh and
how we can help you out in your
blockchain career uh and also what's
changing in the blockchain space in4
we'll be talking about that and careers
in blockchain technology in 2024 what
are the hottest skills Trends you know
we'll be covering those so basically
it's a very interesting session lined up
uh today and also we'll be talking about
the program by IAT cus professional
certificate program in blockchain uh and
what exactly this program offers and
also there'll be a special duration for
the Q&A part so in case uh we'll try to
address uh most of your queries
throughout the session we'll try to take
questions uh throughout the session but
in case we're not able to address your
queries uh we will be taking it towards
the end of the session so please don't
worry about uh if your question does not
get answered uh I'll make sure that you
know all of your queries questions are
basically addressed by our speaker today
who has joined us so as I mentioned
earlier that uh we will be getting to
know a little bit more about you uh as
we start uh so uh I'm just launching a
quick poll here to understand uh you
know what kind of experience do you have
so this will be very interesting to
understand usually folks who join these
webinars you know come from different
different set of experiences so there's
a quick pull on the screen which I've
just launched uh how many years of
experience do you currently have so we
can just start with that uh see I'll
just read out those options for you as
well the first one is currently studying
second one is 0 to 3 years third one uh
3 to 5 years and the last one more than
five years from now uh so U as I was
speaking I can already see that folks
have already started uh voting for The
polium that's great we have gotten a
really active set of audience here and
also aspiring Learners in blockchain so
pretty excited for the session and uh
you can let us know for folks I saw that
a lot of new folks have also joined as
we were basically going to the ground
rules and the agenda of the session here
and I can see introductions coming in on
the chat here so that's great folks have
who already shared the response in the
poll please do introduce yourself on the
chart please let us know where are you
joining us from it's always good to
network right uh these events so I can
see nazul has joined from Bangladesh I
can see tosif has joined from Pakistan
uh I can see naven has joined from Andra
Pradesh and nakul has joined from Punjab
Arin has joined from bangaluru uh so uh
that's great keep the introductions
coming in also just uh folks who have
just joined now just to let you know we
are starting the session uh we're just
doing a quick experience poll here
before we start just to know a little
bit about you uh and we're just doing a
quick R of introduction from the chat
here so once again like I rashar Khan
I'm your host of today's webinar and I
TR to be your host today and you can let
us know where are you joining us from on
the chat here as we start awesome I
think most of the folks have already
shared responses for for the poll here
so I'll just give 5 Seconds more uh to
quickly point out uh basically towards
the poll of how many years of experience
do you currently have so also we've
gotten a pretty interesting responses
here I'll share that I'll just end the
poll in 5 seconds so quickly go and vote
in case you have not voted yet so 5 4 3
2 1 let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you folks so as
we can see here uh very interesting
results here that almost equal amount of
folks have voted so we have gotten
almost 30 percentage votes for more than
5 years of experience folks 35% for
currently studying 35% for 0 to three
years and none have voted for 3 to five
years so that's interesting so uh
basically we have gotten folks from
almost every path of experience here so
thank you so much once again for joining
and also sharing uh that with us um as I
mentioned earlier we already have a
speaker Dr sandep Shukla here with us
uh and uh first of all welcome uh sand
and would like to thank you for taking
the time out uh you know and taking us
through this indust uh interesting
industry master class which will be
doing and uh the topic only seems
interesting I'm excited for it and uh
like would you like to give us your
introduction before we
start yeah so uh thank you Rasha and I
am suep Shukla I am a professor here at
the Indian Institute of Technology kpur
uh and I'm also uh a coordinator for the
national blockchain project uh which has
been running here for Last 5 Years we
have been doing a lot of uh blockchain
research blockchain implementation for
various government agencies like uh we
have done for the Karnataka State we
have done for uh up government and uh we
have also done for uh various institutes
in India for uh self- Sovereign identity
based
certification so uh so and then we also
work a lot on uh uh crime that happens
in the blockchain like the
cryptocurrency uh related crimes so we
have uh developed uh tools and
Technologies for uh uh tracking uh crime
on the cryptocurrency blockchain uh I
also uh coordinate the interdisciplinary
Center for cyber security and cyber
defense for critical infrastructures or
what we call c3i center here I'm also a
uh director of the uh C3 Hub which is a
Technology Innovation Hub in cyber
security uh so so I basically done
multiple different hats before uh coming
to uh IIT kpur in
2015 I uh was a professor at Virginia
Tech uh and State University in uh
Virginia
us uh for about 13 year uh for exactly
13 years years and before that also I
did my U studies uh in New York uh State
University of New York at Albany and I
did my uh some uh before joining the
Academia in 2002 I worked in the
industry for several years uh including
uh uh Verizon and uh Intel uh
Corporation and University of California
at
arw uh thank you so much uh that is a
very long set of experiences and
interesting uh blockchain uh you know uh
projects you're working on so I think we
have been talking about this in other
basically AIML and blockchain webinars
as well so I think we have very
interesting session lined up and we
would love to know your insights in the
session so we're really looking forward
to it uh so let's start let's start with
what's changing in the blockchain space
uh for
2024 yeah so uh as we can see the trends
in blockchain adoption you know uh
basically uh the there have we have seen
increased adoption here so can you uh
take us through these Trends in
blockchain which folks can expect in
2024 yeah so uh actually the blockchain
um as a technology is part of a larger a
broader technology called distributed
Ledger technology right so the uh
distributed Ledger technology is seen as
uh a very you know decentralization of
uh information decentral ation of trust
and decentralization of uh uh you know
uh responsibility of uh running a uh
system so so right now if you think
about uh any system like uh you know web
based systems like Facebook or Google or
YouTube or or any such systems uh they
are actually centralized they are
running from data centers uh uh run by
those companies and every information
that you uh see or every information
that you share there goes to a central
uh uh location uh what happens there is
that then uh you have to trust that
particular organization to actually uh
not only uh keep your information secure
but also not not share with somebody
else without uh your permission and uh
also uh in order to make sure that uh uh
certain things are uh you know U uh you
know responsible uh you know for uh be
for sharing and and for using uh as
information uh now uh what happened in
uh 20089 is that uh there was uh this
mysterious uh work that came out uh in
the form of Bitcoin blockchain and that
first time uh showed how to create a
distributed uh
system in which there is no Central
controller there is nobody who is uh you
know unilaterally responsible for
running the system still the system run
and the system also kept a ledger which
is replicated across all the uh
participating computers which are run by
individuals who whose uh identities are
not necessarily known to everybody and
uh thereby uh distri ruting the notion
of uh responsibility and Trust across uh
uh a large number of individuals or
large number of uh computers run by
individuals so uh so that created a also
a a kind of a
cryptocurrency uh in the form of Bitcoin
but people realized soon that uh it
doesn't have to be about currency or it
doesn't have to be about crypto uh
assets it can be uh used for uh keeping
uh you know things a little more
trustworthy without a uh you know
without uh reposing your uh Trust on a
very on a single entity so for example
if you want to do a property
registration uh did registration now you
go to a sub registers office and they
have their own it system where you
actually uh um you know upload all the
information and they keep it there and
uh when you go back there you have to uh
be uh you have to trust them uh to
ensure that uh they do not tamper with
the information about who owns which
land or which property Etc so uh but if
you do this with a with a blockchain
then uh you do not have to trust a
single entity you have to trust a a
number of entities uh and hope the hope
is is that if the number of entities are
uh you know creating the trust uh
together and they are unlikely to
collude with each other unlikely to uh
enter into a malicious uh uh Enterprise
to actually uh change your information
or or you know uh deprive you of your uh
rights to your property and things like
that so so that's the idea now because
of this idea people started talking
about that uh okay so uh this is a way
to do new uh way of doing for example uh
web technology so as I said that the
current web technology like uh you know
in terms of social media in terms of uh
in terms of any kind of other web
applications like banking application
and so on everything runs from a single
data center run by a particular entity
what if we can have uh a web uh system
uh social Med media system or any other
kind of web application that is not
centrally controlled by a single entity
by but a multiple set of uh uh entities
or multiple individuals who are not
necessarily trusting each other but
overall a trust is created because of
the fact that uh we can assume that not
all of them will collude together so
that's what the idea of web3 is uh uh is
and and it you know blockchain is kind
of of uh uh you know considered the uh
Bas basis of this web three technology
and because of this uh notion that uh
you can do things which are uh which I
can trust better than than I can trust
and Central system there is also uh many
applications many many kind of
applications in the real world where
multiple entities have to interact uh
and and process information and and then
send that information to another entity
for further processing so payment is for
example uh the payment system when you
make a payment to uh let's say a
crossborder payment you make a payment
to somebody in the United States for
example from India the information that
you are sending money your account has
to be debited and somebody else's
account far away has to be credited all
that information has to be shared in
multiple different hops across multiple
different centralized systems so people
started thinking that if we can do a
completely uh transparent system where
everybody every entity that is that is
necess for who for whose work it is
necessary to get that kind of
information uh they can get it uh
without having to worry about you know
uh uh the next party uh not uh behaving
uh you know in a malicious way and
things like that so therefore people
started talking about creating such
application ations like supply chain uh
supply chain or uh crossb payments uh
you know and uh letter of credit in TR
trade Finance this kind of applications
so so there are a lot of applications
people have been experimenting with uh
the
transparency uh efficiency in the sense
that now instead of having to uh you
know uh wait for um multiple days to
have a let's say crossborder payment uh
somebody remitting dollar to the to
India to to their parents that takes
multiple days so this could be done
rather instantaneously in case uh we can
create come up with a blockchain based
solution so so that's that's the kind of
thing that uh people have been imagining
and and also
implementing uh so the the uh uh there
is also applications you know like if
you have a if you have a hospital system
like let's say say Appo or something and
you go go in Chennai app hospital and
then you travel to say Kolkata and you
need to go to the Appo Hospital you want
that information about your past
treatment in Appo Chennai to be visible
in Appo Kolkata so this could be done in
many different ways but blockchain is uh
one U you know eff effective way to do
that so so Healthcare uh patient record
over blockchain for sharing uh across uh
large skill uh you know information
system or if you consider things like
aayushman Bharat where uh your uh
patient record could be accessed from
any government hospital all across India
then you need some kind of a system
where patient records are
instantaneously accessible with security
so so your privacy security Etc are also
a matter of concern there so with that
uh and and also uh we are seeing now
gaming industry is embracing this web3
technology metaverse this Con concept of
metaverse so there are lots of things
that people have been talking about uh
where uh they see blockchain as a as a
way of
implementing uh the things that the more
effectively more efficiently uh more
transparently than before so so that's
that's the uh situation in terms of uh
industrial
Trends uh thank you so much for taking
us to the trends in blockchain in
adoption uh all of them actually sound
very interesting and I see a lot of
career opportunities you know coming out
of it as well which we'll be talking
about in the career slides now let's
talk about the technical advancement in
blockchain so u s like blockchain has
been in the basically industry I would
say in the last five or seven years like
it has basically evolved uh a lot and
there have been a lot of technolog
advantages advancements as well in
blockchain so uh like can you take us
through these advancements and talk
about maybe what has happened and what
we can see in the future as well yeah so
so so blockchain uh you know as I said
it started in 2009 with the with Bitcoin
and uh we started seeing uh you know
initially most of the blockchain
applications were related to
cryptocurrency but as I said that uh you
know soon people realize that it has
many other applications but one of the
major problem with uh blockchain
compared to a centralized database kind
of system is that it is rather slow so
in terms of because you are trying you
are trying to create trust by uh you
know not having any single party to be
trusted therefore there is a protocol
that has to uh execute consensus
protocol that has to execute which makes
things rather slow second problem is
that blockchain there are many different
types of blockchain that has been
developed uh which means that lot of
applications are uh in silos they
actually are developed some is some are
developed in ethereum some are developed
in hyperledger some are developed in
Koda some are developed in some other uh
blockchain technology and therefore what
happens is that if you develop these
things in silos you you basically do not
get the advantage of having this N2 uh
uh nend information transfer end
transparency into end trust kind of
thing so therefore uh second problem is
that we need to have interoperable
Solutions solutions that talk to each
other right two systems that talk to
each other so so that's the second part
so one is the fact that it is rather
slow in terms of getting things uh
getting information processed because of
the distributed trust second is that
it's developed in silos and therefore uh
you know you need to they need to
interrupt
interoperate with each other third thing
was that some of these blockchains like
Bitcoin uh and and until recently
ethereum for example they are based on
some consensus algorithm called proof of
work this proof of work is very very
energy inefficient so so you have to
burn a lot of electric energy to
actually get this consensus done so
therefore uh there is a um it's very
expensive actually to get the get the so
much electricity
um you know uh it's in fact we to run
the Bitcoin Network you basically spend
as much energy as some of the small
European countries so so that is another
issue so because of this you know
multiple different solutions are being
proposed as we speak in last several
years so uh one of the thing is that how
to make blockchains interoperable how do
you make two blockchains talk to each
other they they may be different
technology like one may be ethereum one
may be uh you know PKA dot or or one one
may be you know some other technology
second is that even if they're the same
technology they developed and and run by
two different uh Enterprises or two diff
two different set of uh uh Enterprises
and they need to they need to talk to
each other in order for uh you know
things to work smoothly across multiple
different applications so so that's
interoperability is another
uh area of research and and development
that is going on right now scalability
that is how can how can we process
things much faster is another issue uh
and this is where uh this concept of uh
uh layer to blockchains have come up
right so the blockchains can now like
the blockchains that I mentioned before
Bitcoin ethereum Etc these are uh these
are what we call layer one block chain
and they are they are the con protocol
is very very you know honorous and
therefore they uh process information
rather slowly but uh if you decide that
okay I will actually uh you know relax
these requirements uh this stringent
requirement for consensus a bit then I
can have a side chain on which I I can
do things faster and then eventually you
know I will verify or I will you know
come to the more stringent blockchain to
to uh uh you know write the history of
what I have done in the relax blockchain
so so so that whatever you have done in
the Delux blockchain is further verified
in a batch in the in the layer one
blockchain so that's a layer two
blockchain idea so that's where
lightning Network for example in or or
uh you know uh various other layer to uh
blockchain Concepts have have come uh in
fact this polygon for example which is
one of the in Indian blockchain
companies they actually are layer to
blockchain for ethereum so that's the uh
that's the idea of how to make things
faster uh another way to make things
faster is to actually do what is called
sharding so sharding is an idea that was
uh there in database industry for a long
time so when you have a very large
database you and you want to find
something in that database it takes a
long time so if you Shard the database
that is if you split the data of the
database into multiple different
fragments and then then somehow uh when
you are you have to you are trying to
search something you you have have a way
to know which fragment has the data then
you have to do rather less work because
that fragment has less information than
the entire thing so that's what that's
the that's the idea of sharding so here
also we can do sharding of uh based on
transactions or U uh you know various
other ways so so that the information is
kind of fragmented so and then inter
Shar uh activities are rather limited so
so you actually do most of your
activities within the same same fragment
and then sometimes you have to go across
the fragments but that is uh uh you know
percentage of the such activities being
low you get you gain a lot of
performance so that is the uh uh that is
the idea so uh so so therefore uh in the
in the blockchain space as we see uh we
are seeing basically three different
technological innovation that is going
on one is uh Layer Two blockchains the
or or you can even have layer three uh
you know multi-layer blockchain second
thing is interoperability Technologies
like Cosmos or or pulka dot or or even
in case of uh in case of IBM's uh you
know uh there are multiple other
interoperability Innovations most
recently uh third thing is that you know
you move from uh energy in efficient
consensus protocols to energy efficient
consensus protocols so that's what
happened in
2022 when ethereum went from proof of
work to proof of stake uh consensus so
so these are the exciting things that
are happening in terms of Technology
Innovation in the in the blockchain
space
uh thank you so much for taking us to
the technological advancement in
blockchain uh as you have talked about
the advancement here uh like the
regulatory landscape and uh also the
career opportunities which are coming up
in blockchain can we talk about that as
well yeah so uh well in blockchain there
as I said that the blockchain has
clearly two different uh aspects one is
blockchain that started as a as a way to
uh generate and transfer
cryptocurrencies now cryptocurrencies
are are actually not uh uh well uh the
currency usually is is country specific
it's actually uh uh you know like India
has rupees and and us has US dollars or
Singapore has Singapore dollars Etc uh
Europe has Euros now these are
currencies right and these are actually
created by the Central Bank of that
jurisdiction so it could be uh Reserve
Bank of India or or Federal Reserve in
the US or or Singapore monetary
Authority for Singapore and so on now
when you create uh you know something
that uh you claim to be currency uh it
becomes a little bit of dicey
proposition because uh you know uh it's
actually not something that is
government
created Central Bank created it's
something that you are calling currency
so you can actually uh you
know take a take a bottle and say that
I'm going to use this to exchange uh
exchange food right exch in exchange for
food I will use this water bottle right
so that then your then your water bottle
can be used into some limited extent as
some kind of a currency but that does
not make it a really currency in the
sense that uh uh that these that the
Central Bank uh Central Bank uh currency
uh uh you know like rupees and dollar
Etc are so so there has been a lot of
friction between the cryptocurrency
blockchain uh proponents and the uh and
the and the businesses that are
associated with this cryptocurrency
blockchain like uh cryptocurrency
exchanges uh and The Regulators the the
uh like Reserve Bank of India or Federal
Reserve or uh and also uh some uh
because of the price fluctuation of the
cryptocurrency uh it does not have the
property of a currency currencies don't
fluctuate like that like Bitcoin became
65,000 US dollar into in 2021 and then
by April 2022 it was like 20 below
$220,000 right so you cannot have that
uh so so then there is also claim that
uh cryptocurrencies are actually
Securities that is like like like stocks
uh so so these are kind of um you know
frictions that are there uh uh so so
there has been a lot of talk about
whether some jurisdictions will ban
cryptocurrency some jurisdictions will
uh allow cryptocurrency so recently
G20 countries they came up with a with a
uh uh recommendation
that countries really cannot ban
cryptocurrency because it is very
difficult to you know enforce the ban
although they say that you know it
cryptocurrencies are actually uh you
know problematic in terms of financial
stability of a country and all that
stuff but it cannot be
really banned because it's very
difficult to do it so therefore they ask
for ask that everybody comes up with
some regulations and they give a broad
outline of what the regulations might
look like so so that gave you gave us a
give the people some kind of a
regulatory Clarity although it's still
not there but at least people are kind
of uh expecting that the most
jurisdictions will not ban it so
therefore most jurisdictions will
probably allow it as some kind of a
asset class not NE not as currency but
as some asset class asset class like
stocks and and bonds and and things like
that so therefore there will be
regulations and the once the regulations
are there there will be a lot more
clarity about where this is going like
which direction it is going and so on uh
so that is the regulation regulatory
aspects the other issue is that uh the
uh there are more people now who
understand blockchain technology uh
because of the various opportunities to
learn and various opport many
universities now uh teach uh so courses
in blockchain we do uh here uh in our
curriculum uh not not as elective not
not a not a requirement but as elective
and then there are lot of courses like
this course like in that simply learn
runs with I kpur so people are getting
more and more U you know uh getting a
Workforce that will work on your
blockchain project is getting slightly
easier now there are uh ethical
considerations here as I said because uh
lot of times because the the nature of
cryptocurrencies uh the sudo anonymity
of cryptocurrencies lot of uh uh illicit
activities happen there like for example
money laundering and and and things like
that so so that is another area where uh
the government is pretty concerned um
but um there is also uh many governments
now coming up with their own digital
currency uh which is not like
cryptocurrency which is very different
cryptocurrency which is basically a
digital form of their own uh own uh
currency like for example in India now
we have um eupe which is the digital
rupees uh which may use blockchain
technology for its implementation but
it's not cryptocurrency cryptocurrencies
are very different from
cbdcs and uh also uh there are some um
work in in terms of uh compliance you
know there once you have regulations you
have to comply with the regulations but
there is also many other compliance
things like for example you have to
comply with certain accounting standards
and and things like that in Banks and so
on so we have seen some uh activities
there in terms of creating compliance
technology uh on uh on
blockchain uh so uh also because of this
regulation issues and and uh there is
also this no of real world asset
tokenization so you you can actually use
a blockchain to tokenize for example a a
property or you can tokenize uh gold or
you can tokenize Commodities and and the
question is and then you can uh sell and
and buy uh fraction of those properties
or fraction of a gold bar uh through
this tokens because tokens are digital
so they can be fractionalized but
because of this new new kind of assets
uh there would be legal and other other
issues that will come up there would be
uh regulatory issues legal issues uh you
know uh so therefore there is also
interest in many uh in the legal
fraternity there is interest in uh
learning uh about blockchain technology
tokenization and these kind of
Concepts uh thank you so much for taking
us through the regularity uh landscape
and the career opportunities here uh we
have gotten gone through the trends here
we have gotten through the technological
advancements here in blockchain in the
coming year and and Beyond uh so uh just
one
second so
sorry some Technic issue yes we are back
uh so yeah so we have talked about the
trends here in blockchain we have talked
about the technological advant
advancements here in blockchain in 2024
and Beyond and we have also talked about
the career opportunities here in
blockchain which will arise you know
through a lot of things we have
discussed we'll be talking more about
the skills and careers you know and the
tools which are upcoming in the upcoming
slides here but uh maybe uh something
you can take us through the summary of
what's changing in the blockchain space
in24 for the folks just to summarize a
bit because you have talked about a lot
of things here yeah so uh well as I said
that the blockchain technology has has
uh you know is is evolving really really
fast so couple of a couple of terms that
are are you know kind of uh spoken about
in the in the parland of blockchain one
is web 3 that is the uh new web
technologies that will be decentralized
uh there is also uh the tokenization of
assets including real world assets uh we
also uh are are seeing a lot of use of
blockchain technology in the uh um uh in
the uh uh
currency space where which is not
cryptocurrency but government currencies
the Fiat currencies like eup in India
cbdc the Central Bank digital currencies
and uh because of uh and and then in
terms of technological changes uh we
seeing uh we are seeing in blockchain
space uh you know uh scalability through
uh layer layer layering of blockchains
so layer to blockchains we are seeing
interoperability to connect multiple
different blockchain based applications
uh you know so that they can
interoperate with each other and we are
seeing this uh idea of uh you know uh
tokenization of uh uh you know use of
smart contracts to actually create and
and uh um to to try you know manage the
life cycle of tokens so and because of
these uh we need uh you know not only
technology people but also legal and uh
regulatory experts in the blockchain uh
uh blockchain
technology okay uh thank you so much for
taking us to the summary here now let's
move on to uh to talk about the careers
in blockchain development in 2024 so
here uh we can see the hottest skills in
the blockchain space you upcoming in
2024 uh maybe can you take us through
these skills
here yeah so so first of all um uh you
know blockchain development like you
know there is always a new scope for a
uh new blockchain uh technology like so
so we have so many like Bitcoin we have
ethereum we have layer two ethereums
like like polygon we have uh we have
Solana we have Iota we have Koda we have
uh uh you know various uh types of
blockchains and then there could be many
other uh blockchain uh technology that
uh so so many times people are not happy
with the technology they it doesn't give
them all the things that they want so
they go on developing new blockchain
technology so blockchain development is
obviously one uh thing uh that uh uh
that is one might be interested in uh
the other thing that would people might
be interested in is to develop smart
contracts how do you develop smart
contracts uh uh to develop applications
uh distributed applications uh D apps uh
also uh you can um think about securing
the blockchain because blockchain is
running on many different nodes so you
have to secure them you have to secure
the smart contracts uh as I said that
you know you need to have cross chain
integration that is the
interoperability uh so and then how to
govern a blockchain because a blockchain
is a distributed system so so you have
to have rules and and methods for making
sure that the blockchain actually runs
uh uh you know all the time so that
people have access to the
functionalities that are provided by the
blockchain uh it should not be it there
has to be cyber security risk assessment
all this stuff so blockchain governance
is very important uh in some uh uh
blockchain all the information uh is
public but in many applications such as
medical application or financial
applications you have to use encryption
mechanism and and maybe
you know Advanced encryption mechanism
like multi-party computation or um you
know uh zero knowledge proof Etc uh that
you will require uh to actually provide
privacy as along with
transparency some new applications of
blockchain is in the decentralized
finance so
defy nfts are um non-fungible tokens and
asset tokenization this is another area
where where uh there would be interest
uh supply chain for blockchain uh Dow
management Dow are decentralized
decentralized autonomous organization
where the governance is completely
autonomous uh so that's that that's
another uh interesting uh area of uh
that that can be enabled by blockchain
uh understanding uh if you if you're
going to develop a new token uh let's
say uh you are an airline or you are you
are a restaurant chain or you are a uh
grocery chain and you want to provide uh
credits uh points uh for purchase for
the purchase of the customers so you can
instead of giving it in terms of
notional points you can give them as
tokens so how would you make that token
viable and that token's life cycle will
be managed and so on so that's brings
the tokenomics and then uh there is also
of course decentralized Identity or
self- Sovereign identity
uh there is also uh blockchain analytics
that is uh when you analyze
cryptocurrency blockchains to see what
is going on and uh you know in terms of
whether there is any illegal activities
going on in in a particular blockchain
uh that is blockchain analytics and then
there is a gaming Plus decentralized
Finance these are some of the hottest
skills in blockchain
space uh thank you so much SII for
taking us to these hottest skills in the
block space in 2024 uh there are plenty
of skills you know folks can take up and
let's talk about the tools libraries
platforms you know they should be
learning uh and we have covered like few
here I'm pretty sure there are many more
but maybe you can uh take us like you
know what we'll be like a very important
tool library or platform for someone
who's completely coming from a different
background you know does not have any
knowledge of blockchain where would you
recommend them to start with in any of
the tools
here yeah so for anybody who wants to
learn blockchain uh from this from the
beginning uh for them to understand how
Bitcoin uh blockchain works is very
important even though you know you may
you are not going to probably do
cryptocurrency blockchains and so on but
the basic concepts of um you know
peer-to-peer
communication broadcasting information
across all the nodes uh uh creation of
uh you know uh transactions validating
transactions uh combining transactions
into blocks um mining of the blocks
consensus algorithms all these things
are in the Bitcoin uh blockchain and
therefore it is very very important to
understand Bitcoin blockchain even
though that's where not not necessarily
where you will be uh developing your
applications and so on but bit Bitcoin
is a very
illustrative educational uh you know uh
blockchain Concepts and it it basically
introduces all the basic concepts of
blockchain
uh then uh bit but Bitcoin does not give
you much programmability you cannot
write uh you cannot automize uh or uh
create autonomy on the Bitcoin
blockchain easily uh although the newest
version of Bitcoin especially some of
the forks of Bitcoin has introduced that
so ethereum is probably uh the second
thing that you have to learn and you
will learn how to write smart
contracts uh then uh after ethereum and
block uh uh Bitcoin so the for ethereum
smart contracts you have to learn
solidity you have to use truffle for
create creating the environment for
experimenting with ethereum and then uh
for a for a
non permission blockchain uh sorry a
perm for a permission blockchain uh you
can learn hyperledger uh and Hyper
through hyper Leger Fabric and uh you
can also learn a few other uh
blockchains uh
because you know if you want to actually
learn things uh eventually the you know
in a in a course of blockchain uh you
can only learn a few things uh but you
have to be at the end of a course you
will be ready to learn on your
own much more and to do that you have to
have a diversity of different concepts
that you should learn so Bitcoin
ethereum hyperledger they will give you
the diversity of different concepts from
which you can bootstrap your knowledge
so that's the that's the idea of
this uh thank you so much for uh you
know giving us an idea basically where
you can start and where you can
basically go from there as well uh
obviously a lot of these tools platforms
libraries have covered in the program
which we'll be talking about uh but also
we have talked about the hottest skills
uh in the blockchain space in 2024 you
know what uh career paths they can take
up but let's focus on these trending
blockchain career paths you know which
which will be uh pretty uh you know in
demand in
2024 yeah so um well whether it will be
in demand in 2024 is you know you know I
don't know but uh but at least these are
the various uh various blockchain career
paths right so you can become a
blockchain developer you can uh most
blockchain applications require a front
end that is usually you know web
Technology based so you can have
blockchain web designer you can become a
solution architect when you you know
blockchain developers is who actually
you know you are asked to develop a
particular application smart contracts
and so on uh you do that but solution
architect actually decides which
blockchain technology is the most
important uh which most relevant to this
particular problem statement how it
should be architected and and whether it
should be permission or permissionless
whether the uh you know smart contracts
will be uh you know factor refactored or
or there will be a monolithic large
smart contract all those concepts are
are actually from a blockchain solution
architect a project manager would
actually manage the manage a blockchain
based project you know when customer
wants a blockchain based application
designed uh user experience designer
this is uh something that uh uh you know
that front end will require uh quality
engineer will be actually working on the
validating uh testing the smart
contracts and so on so that you know it
doesn't have uh security uh bugs and so
on or or it it might also debug the
performance issues and so on and legal
consultant is uh you know when you have
a blockchain based application you know
you have multiple Enterprises involved
in in in maintaining the blockchain so
there will be legal contracts between
these entities uh you know apportioning
responsibility of who is responsible in
case of a security breach in case of a
data leak and and so on so forth so
legal issues might come up in the
blockchain
space uh thank you so much SI for taking
us to these trending blockchain careers
you know K they can take up at 24
obviously we cannot confirm or Justify
if these will be in demand but
definitely we can basically uh you know
give them an idea about you know what
can be those career paths you can you
can take up what are the possible career
paths so moving on as we are have talked
about the skills here we have talked
about the career paths here obviously if
you're aspiring to become a blockchain
expert so the salary also matters right
so as the demands are increasing the
salaries are also basically are much
more in demand uh so uh for example here
the annual salary of a blockchain
developer in India uh minimum salary
basically you will get six lakhs perom
and an average of of 18 lakhs perom and
a maximum of 35 lakhs perom to start
with and the hiring companes we have
here uh basically are IBM white Force
colins Aerospace and evi being one of
those companies here and so basically we
have talked about the skills here we
have talked about the trends in career
here what you can basically take up in
the space of blockchain here so uh and
what exactly is stopping you from
becoming a blockchain expert here we
would love to know what is the biggest
challenge here when it comes to taking
of a blockchain career I'm pretty sure
you're here because you're interested in
a blockchain career and you're aspiring
to become a blockchain expert or seeing
yourself in a blockchain uh you know uh
space here uh in 2084 and uh so we would
love to know you can see this uh this
quick poll have launched uh where
basically we would love to know what
exactly is stopping you from becoming a
blockchain expert developer uh taking up
the career here so from all the hottest
Trends skills and the career paths we
have taken up the basically how the
blockchain space is going to change in
2024 and Beyond we have talked about
those things uh so you can see four
quick options here this is a multiple
choice question so in case you want to
select multiple options you can do that
here in case this poort does not cover
your responses here you can let us know
what is the biggest challenge you're
facing when it comes to taking up a
career in blockchain or becoming a
blockchain expert here so you can let us
know in the chat or in the Q&A box here
that will be also okay so I just read
out those options for you here in the
poll here uh so uh the first one here is
I can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum second one I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and the third
one I find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos and the last one my
work shule won't allow me enough time
for learning as we saw uh with the
experience for that a lot of experienced
folks have joined us so I think that
option definitely makes sense and I can
see the polls are quickly moving as we
speaking and uh folks are pretty active
here uh because we have gotten most of
the responses in the poll here but we
would love to know from few of the folks
who are still basically going and making
a choice in the poll here so I'll give
10 seconds for the poll here uh before
we move on so we would love to know what
is your biggest challenge here when it
comes to taking up a blockchain career
aspiring for a blockchain career
becoming a blockchain expert
here awesome I think I'll just give five
seconds more for the poll here because
uh we have gotten uh almost plenty of
responses from the folks who have joined
us so five 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and also share the results with
you folks so let's see uh as we can see
here that uh we have gotten 56% of the
votes for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready 50%
of the folks have voted for my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
Learning and uh 31% of the folks have
voted for I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum and few
of the folks have voted for I find it
difficult to learn from prerecorded
videos so so thank you so much for
sharing the biggest concern biggest
challenge here you have you know when
you are trying to Aspire for a
blockchain career so uh let me introduce
you uh IAT canus professional
certificate program and blockchain uh
this comes with a comprehensive uh
curriculum with an industry Aline
learning path you get access to
integrated Labs Hands-On projects which
you can work on for practical experience
uh which we also got you know as one of
the biggest concerns right we'll be
covering about the projects in the
upcoming slides and online live virtual
classroom which get access to uh with
peer and inst interaction here and also
uh this program will be flexible to fit
your lifestyle and schedule uh as the
program duration is of four months but
you can just complete it by giving five
to 10 hours per week so and uh we will
talk about how this program basically
builds your uh blockchain skill step by
step uh but also just to let you know
folks thank you so much for uh you know
interesting questions in the Q&A box
here uh we are very eager to address all
of all of your queries here uh before we
move on uh so uh please have some
patience we'll be addressing them pretty
soon so uh I think s can you take us
through these uh steps you know what
exactly happens in this program uh in
blockchain yeah so uh in the beginning
uh you know you go through an
orientation session then you uh go into
as I said that you know to understand
the Bitcoin uh uh blockchain technology
uh will give you a very solid if you
understand Bitcoin very well uh you you
are halfway there you you understand uh
how the uh blockchain technology works
and then you go into the smart contract
based blockchain so you have to go to
ethereum and learn to write smart
contracts and so on uh while doing the
Bitcoin and uh you know also the
ethereum you understand the concept of
consensus and some cryptographic
Concepts and then you go move on to the
uh the permission uh blockchain like
hyperledger Fabric and then you actually
learned some applications and then you
have to do a Capstone project which is
uh you know curated uh by industry
people for the uh for the students uh so
that they can actually do some uh uh you
know realistic projects uh U you know in
the in the blockchain of their choice uh
and then also use that um experience in
their in their
CV uh thank you so much for taking us
through the steps uh in the program how
basically builds your blockchain skills
step by step also the elective here uh
the I khur academic master classes which
you get access to are completely
optional it is up to you if you want to
take it it comes as a part of the
program we don't charge anything extra
for that uh now talking about the
eligibility and prequisites here I think
someone asked about the eligibility part
here so let me just share that with you
so need to have a basic understanding of
mathematics basic understanding of java
is preferred here if you take up the
program uh I think it was pretty clear
from the explanation even s gave uh and
um also you need to have a bachelor's
degree with 50% or higher marks uh and
no work experience is required for this
so uh folks who basically don't have a
work experience that's totally uh okay
and also uh simply Lear comes uh with a
job service that helps you with your job
s uh where uh this is this is for Indian
earners I'll share the link of the
program you can check out for your own
region as well uh so here you get access
to free access to expert webinars and
career events with the industry is you
get options to choose from Real World
projects across Industries you know
which you can work on through this
program and all the tools and the
platforms which we have talked about are
covered in this program as well uh and
basically the job versus Services is in
association with IM job so we have
partnered with them in which you get
resume review interview prep you know
one-on-one interview prep Services uh
resume reev service from that so U as we
have talked about uh basically the
program here let's take a few uh burning
questions which we have gotten uh on the
Q&A Bo as promised so let me just
quickly uh as we have gotten a lot of
questions let me do one thing let me
just uh put down a question uh for you
on the chat here s so maybe it will be
easier for you to you know find when we
take so I can see U I've just shared one
question here from the Q&A box uh we can
see this is from um maybe like I'm not
able to make out the N I'm so sorry I'll
just read out the question uh so for an
established data architect what are the
opp oties in
blockchain well data architecture I
assume is uh you know designing uh
working on data model uh and also
architecting the uh uh the database uh
schemas and and things like that or
refactoring the database uh uh this kind
of stuff so uh I don't think that there
is a direct um connection to data
architecture uh
experience with blockchain
um of course a person with such kind of
experience will be uh uh you know uh
very um efficient in taking up uh
blockchain technology uh basic knowledge
and so on but I I don't think that there
would be a direct correlation with the
if I understand what data architect
means uh uh correctly then I don't think
that there is any specific uh immediate
Advantage uh thank you so much for
taking up that question please let us St
on the chart or in the Q&A box if that
answers your question and also you can
ask us in followup question as well uh
so we have one more question by Ravi
here uh who basically asked that
application of blockchain in e-commerce
industry well application of blockchain
uh uh e-commerce industry so e-commerce
industry is where you actually U uh
you know put a store on the on the on
the web and uh you actually customers go
to the website and make
payments and uh uh you have uh in the
back end you have warehouse and and uh
you have a inventory uh database and and
things like that so um I'm not sure as I
mean there is a much advantage of uh you
know doing that kind of a system into a
into a blockchain based system uh
probably
not okay uh thank you so much for
answering that S I hope that answers
your question uh we uh have gotten one
question the starting of the session uh
like I just point that out uh so
basically says that I am a software
developer uh with over three plus years
of experience uh and I'm planning to
switch either to a IML or blockchain you
know career uh in 2024 so uh will this
course actually help me out uh you know
in basically switching to the blockchain
space and learning a a lot about you
know blockchain and basically moving my
career towards blockchain
completely well um uh this course will
certainly you know get you um well
introduced to uh uh well introduced to
blockchain technology how it works and
and um get you uh you know uh practical
Hands-On
exercises uh to write smart contracts
and and and put you know set up a
hyperledger environment or or an
ethereum environment and so on and and
and in the Capstone project you will do
something uh that is uh probably uh you
know will be interesting to you uh but
uh you know eventually no course will
make you immediately ready for a
blockchain uh expertise uh you you will
not be considered a blockchain expert
just because you took and and
successfully completed a course you have
to uh use the use the in you know basic
things that you learned and the
experience that you have in Hands-On and
so on to actually hone your skill create
create your own projects put them on
GitHub so that you can actually brag
about them to your potential uh
potential uh uh you know employer and
employer can actually go to GitHub and
get get your uh uh get your thing um you
know downloaded and see try out your
things and and see the quality of the
your code and all that stuff and and
then only you will uh be considered you
know for good good uh jobs in in that
you know in blockchain uh uh technology
uh so so I'd say you know uh while it is
uh interesting uh uh to do but uh you
know your expectation should be
uh not that I you know I do it and then
next day people are knocking at my door
for you know blockchain job that is not
how it works definitely definitely I
totally agree to that I think uh a
course can definitely help you give a
direction and give you that knowledge
you know towards you can go but you need
to basically keep updating your skills
keep working on you know I think we have
gotten few questions about the projects
here uh and keep basically U connecting
with people of you know similar space
there are a lot of things that keep can
be done you know
Beyond actually studying something or
taking up course I totally agree to that
but definitely the course definitely
helps you giving some kind of
perspective for someone who does not
have any idea about blockchain so I
think we'll take more questions um you
know if you have some time left uh but
as we have talked about the skills you
have we talked about the trends in
blockchain what are the career paths you
know which will be in demand in
blockchain which you can take a few
examples of that we have talked about
what's exactly changing in the
blockchain space in 2024 and Beyond and
we have talked about a lot of things
which you can cover through this program
by IAT kpur the professional certificate
program in blockchain which is of four
months duration so uh we would love to
know are you interested in enrolling
into the professional certificate
program in blockchain by kpur also not
to forget uh the bonus offer you'll be
getting for attending this webinar so
that is pretty uh you know amazing as
well so I've just quick launched a quick
poll here we would love to know your
interest here so basically we can uh you
know learning Consultants from Simply
learn can get back to you with you know
a much more detailed walk through of the
program if you have any questions we can
do that so you can see a quick call here
with yes and no here in case you're
planning to join Maybe not immediately
within uh six months within uh three
months you know or within basically two
months or next year so we have a lot of
cards which go throughout the year so
the bonus offer still will be applicable
you know whenever you take up the
program so you don't have to worry about
that I obviously will be you know asking
you when do you plan to enroll what
exactly approximate uh timeline you are
planning to enroll as well so we will
have an idea basically you know when
exactly are you planning to take up the
course so I think a good explanatory
walk through of the program is something
you know you can share with us over the
poll here as option yes and uh this is
something will help us out you know in
order to reach out to you and even take
you through the program in much more
detail of by i k here so I think as I
was speaking I am seeing almost 95%
interest towards the program so that's
great so uh but I'll just I think I'll
give 15 seconds more for the uh poll
here and meanwhile uh we will uh if we
have any time left we'll take more
questions but actually we have exceeded
the time of the session so I think we'll
just quickly um you know like I'll take
you through the enrollment steps of the
program here and also the program fee
and the schedule I think someone asked
about that as well so I will quickly
take you through the upcoming cohort
here uh so we'll take just five minutes
more for that so I think I'll just uh
give 10 seconds more for the poll year
so again like so uh are you interested
in enrolling into the professional
certificate program in blockchain by
kpur would you like to explore this
program mod so you can let us know by
answering yes to the poll which you see
on the screen here and this will help us
uh in reaching on to you you know in
much more detailed walk through of the
program here to give you a much more
idea from much more than what we have
covered uh in this program as
well awesome I think uh we uh tried
answering a few questions uh but uh we
are a little bit out of time here so I
think uh we will uh basically take maybe
few more minutes for the enrollment
steps and the program fee schedule and
few more things you know we would love
from you when do you plan to enroll so I
think I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll here before we move on
because I can see a lot of folks have
already shared their responses about the
poll here and that's pretty positive so
uh so I think 5 Seconds more for the
poll for a few of the folks who are
still thinking about it so uh five 5 4 3
2 1 let me quickly end the poll and
quickly take you through the enrollment
steps here of the program here so as we
can see the enrollment steps uh there
are very three simple easy steps you can
follow you need to submit an application
to us at ask us at simply le.net based
on that your application will be going
for a review uh based on the eligibility
and PR sites we have already shared with
you and also based on all these things
you'll be getting uh basically a
learning consultant will be contacting
you from Simply and taking you on a much
more detailed walk through of the
program if you have any questions about
the program as I as I shared with you
earlier and also the program fee for
this one is 1 lakh 169,000 uh INR rupees
and also uh if you're looking for Emi
financing options we have available uh
for as low as
5,750 51 rupees per month so here the
next upcoming coh the the most recent
coh uh which is uh happening on 14th of
November the induction and the classes
for this will be starting on 18th of
November and as I mentioned earlier that
um we have a these cohorts you know
coming throughout the year but we do
take only 25 to 30 folks per coh in
order to make sure you're getting all
the attention you know that is required
when you join this program so that is Al
also we do also um if you need any more
assistance you can reach out to us at
ask us at s.net I'll share that email ID
and even the program link on the chat
here for folks I noticed have joined
from different countries as well you can
check out for your own region there so
uh moving on uh so for folks who have
already shared interest towards
enrollment and also uh basically would
be interested in the bonus offer as well
for the program so I've shared a quick
poll here and we would love to know how
soon do you plan to enroll into the
program so there are four quick options
here uh so if someone who basically
wants to join immediately uh in the
cohort which I've SE shown you and maybe
the next one you can choose the option
immediately and if you are still
thinking about it not sure where
basically not planned it yet so I would
suggest select the last three options
which is the most suitable for you
because you can Avail the you know bonus
offer in any of those options so that is
not an issue but I would recommend to
choose one so this will give us an idea
when exactly to reach out to you uh the
learning Consultants you know from C who
basically be reaching out to you uh for
taking through a much more detailed walk
through of the program before you end so
I'll just read out these options here
immediately within 3 months within 6
months and more than 6 months from now
so I think I'll just give 5 Seconds more
for the poll here and S so sorry like I
think we just extended by a few minutes
is that okay with you
yeah awesome I think most of the folks
have already shared their responses for
the poll here but I'll just uh give five
seconds more for folks who have shared
enrollment interest please do that uh
because this is something that will be
helpful for us when we reach out to you
awesome so 5 Seconds more I'll give for
the poll here so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and let's move on
to the next last poll here of the
session and uh basically this is just to
understand if you need assistance in
enrolling into the program so there are
two quick options here this is for folks
who have already have shared with us you
know when to basically they want to
enroll they want are interested in going
through the program in much more detail
and uh they also basically have shared
with us when do you plan to enroll so
please do let us know if you need any
help in enrolling and obviously simply L
will be assisting you with that
happily I think I'll just give 10
seconds more for this pole as I was
speaking most of the folks have already
shared the responses we've gotten a very
quick audience here and
uh awesome I think uh I'll just give
five seconds more because I see that
folks have already shared the responses
for the poll here so 5 4 3 2 one let me
quickly end the poll and uh as we have
exceeded like the session by a few
minutes uh first of all would like to
thank s uh you know like for first of
all taking the time out and taking us
through this industry Master Class
session on blockchain basically what we
can expect in the future in the next
year uh s would you like to see
something to the crowd before we end the
session
um no I think I think I am fine I'm kind
of sleepy now it's okay I think yeah
definitely I think we should end the
session now and good night uh to
everyone good morning good afternoon I
think we saw people joining from
different regions but yeah definitely
definitely it's uh basically time to
close the session and uh have a good
night have everyone take care and thank
you for being an amazing on thank you so
much once again thank you good
night